[Musique]
les assises nationales du transport
aérien elles ont débuté le 20 mars
dernier elles se poursuivront jusqu'au
mois de septembre avec avec il faut le
préciser
un volet propre à nos pays bonjour serge
chimie bonjour en tout cas maintenaient
députés et vous avez été désigné serge
et chimie par elisabeth bornes la
ministre du transport désigné pour
présider une commission performance
outre-mer de ces assises sur le
transport aérien
car il faut le préciser l'objectif
numéro un de ces assisses et de
rechercher la performance de ce secteur
oui il faut saluer cette initiative
cette double initiative parce qu'on y
allait aussi de l'aérien il ya une
réflexion sur l'ensemble du territoire
national mais qu'un volet spécifique en
outre-mer généralement quand on fait un
texte de loi un projet il ya simplement
une sorte de petite addition promer
banalisée c'est pas le cas et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que j'ai accepté de
présider le volet où tu reviens d alors
on parle de performance économique en
sept pôles vital le transport aérien du
développement des développements peu
près ce que le dira si nous sommes une
île
ouais notre compagnie le désenclavement
se fait soit par la mer soit par l'air
donc la question du désenclavement
aérien est vital
c'est véritablement quelque chose
d'essentiel et de difficultés ce que
nous sommes en plus à 8000 km la france
pour parler de le première 10000 12000
pour le pacifique l'océan indien donc il
n'y a pas que la martinique
les rouleaux donc c'est ça concerne
l'ensemble de l'outre-mer d'une manière
générale donc la question de
l'attractivité d'une manière générale
est essentielle mais l'attractivité
économique est encore plus important le
développement alors lorsqu'on dit aérien
on voit seulement les avions mais c'est
pas que ça il ya le développement des
infrastructures galets passage il bien
être social l'environnement à prendre en
considération finalement c'est quelque
chose de très lourd ces assises c'est ça
ce sont des aspects d'ordre général que
vous alliez en australie ou en
martinique ou à paris ou ailleurs
eh bien vous avez ces éléments l'un des
deux technologies de performances
technologiques économiques etc
mais pour nous c'est très particulier
parce que nous sommes à la fois dans un
trip l'enclavement un activement par
rapport à ce que nous appelons
l'hexagone c'est à dire ce que certains
appellent la main
au pôle de manière abusive oui ça s'est
amélioré au cours de ces dernières
années par là la fréquence des vols sont
assurés par jour dont mais cependant il
reste épaules m je sais les aborder on
va les aborder et puis deuxièmement il
ya l'enclavement aussi par rapport à
notre géographie cordiale c'est-à-dire
pour je prends l'exemple ou non mais
pour la réunion c'est l'afrique du sud
pot pour nous c'est les états unis avec
centrale amérique du sud et puis aussi
l'enclavement nous même par nous mêmes
c'est à dire martinique s insère
aéroports poil en guyane ya plein
tarifaire aussi qui se poseraient 2000
euros le billet depuis 2000 euros le
billet est la question des questions et
beaucoup plus complexe on imagine c'est
pour ça qu'il faut absolument trouver
des solutions alors serge letchimy
abordons tout de suite les thèmes qui
fâche le prix du billet pas moi sans une
nouvelle pétition sur internet
exigeant que les prix soient plafonnées
voir encadré va prendre deux exemples
fort de france cayenne on l'a dit autour
du millier d'euros fort de france pointe
à pitre 300 euros malgré certaines
affiches racoleuses hautement trompeuse
une cinquantaine d'euros par certaines
compagnies on se fout de la gueule de
qui concerne le prix des avions
j'ai clairement dit à amman en born est
ce que vous voulez que je préside ce
volet outre-mer de manière un petit peu
de luis tu simple et jolie clairement
ses six essais plus c'est pas la peine
de me choisir parce que je veux des
conditions très précises
elle a joué le jeu dans le sens où elle
a clairement posées par écrit les
problèmes et parmi ces plaies mme la
question des prix des billets comment se
fait-il qu'en soient amenés à payer près
de 1200 euros pour alan guyane et que
pour aller à paris on a un des billets
pendant les saisons haute à 300-400
euros
la brusque avec à passer à 1200 euros
pour un aller-retour dans des périodes
creuses
il y a un vrai problème 3 ses propres
titres la truite en europe et qui est
une liaison extrêmement importante c'est
pas de 500000 personnes qui voyagent pas
donc nous en plus nous avons quand même
une lune trafic aérien qui est très
important c'est 12 millions de passagers
en soule outre-mer et 4 millions dans la
relation avec ce que nous disons
l'hexagone il n'y a pas de problème de
marché est en pleine d'organisation
est-ce qu'il faut arriver à des
régulations depuis on est ce que le
politique peut intervenir là dessus
vicioso politique intervenir mais ne
sont pas d un marché régulé
il faut trouver des solutions pour
assurer une compétitivité et very
vérifier qu'ils aient pas c'était cas
entre les deux périodes notamment pour
l'hexagone
et puis je faire jouer clairement le
politique peut jouer dans le sens où les
obligations de service public existe la
liaison entre cayenne et maripasoula
liaisons entre les îles de l'océan
pacifique
le désenclavement entre la martinique et
la guadeloupe beaucoup plus dynamique
tout ça ça fait partie des obligations
de l'état oui et puis si ça ne
désenclavement intérieur par rapport à
les îles de la caraïbe surtout que on
nous renvoie sans cesse au visage serge
letchimy cesser ces billets qui sont
subventionnées entre la france et la
corse
oui bon pourquoi pas encore des jaloux
je n'aime pas trop ces comparaisons à
une histoire entre la france et la corse
est la seule chose c'est que aujourd'hui
nous avons des déplacements extrêmement
fréquent avec un soutien à la mobilité
pour la promotion professionnelle un
soutien à la mobilité sociale il faut
l'amplifier pas seulement dans le sens
où martinique paris mais aussi dans le
sens paris martinique
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de frères et
soeurs qui sont là bas et qui n'ont pas
les moyens de vous voir revenir une fois
à leur domicile
effectivement et surtout le vrai haut en
période de fêtes les fêtes de fin
d'année ont envie d'être en famille le
prix plafond c'est c'est ça peut être
vrai espoir cette fantasque c'est une
une illusion tout simplement non nous
avons les assises on a les débats qui
commencent bientôt nous allons avoir un
rassemblement pratiquement de tous les
acteurs à paris
vers le 6 juillet j'ai commencé les
auditions je poursuivais résolution à
paris à martigny combe redoux je dois me
rendre logiciels parmi les enjeux je le
répète extrêmement important peut-on
ouvrir le ciel et dans la caraïbe de
telle sorte qu'on puisse avoir une
meilleure connexion avec l'argentine
le panama et les états unis
c'est sa grâce à karine roy camille ça
très bien avancé avec nos régional ends
mais dans la caraïbe peut-on être mieux
connecter sur barbade jamaïque saint
domingue sainte-lucie dominique c'est ça
il ya et un à coke était passé récemment
karibe sky avec air antilles express et
d'autres compagnies a fonctionné pour
moi c'est le grand défi qu c'est qu'on
soit pas du tout étranger à notre
géographie de proximité et quels sont
les outils qui pourraient nous permet
d'aller beaucoup plus vite notamment les
aéroports travail conséquent effet par
frantz thodiard martinique mais tous les
aéroports doivent être modernisées et
comment les en les finances et derrière
ça si vous faites venir des gens des
états unis d'australie de d'europe
et puis on n'a pas la plateforme
économique touristique où les accueillir
et meilleures conditions on n'a pas le
transport pouvoir les accueillir et de
leur évolution chiffre tombe bien nous
avons pas les la qualité de l'accueil
sous les noms de l'art de la gastronomie
ça il faut continuer à oeuvrer pour que
l'effort fait pour faire venir les gens
soient aussi accompagnée d'une aide de
l'existence d'une performance local
interne ça dépend de nous pas de paris
serge chimie on sait que vous êtes grand
amateur de football on a vu dernièrement
les joueurs du club franciscain pour
aller et revenir de saint domingue
comment ça a été grande aventure pour
aller tout près la moins de deux heures
d'avion ainsi alors qu'on prône la
caraïbe la caraïbe la caraïbe depuis 40
ans oui mais on se complaît aussi vous
venez de faire un petit peu mais ça il
faut chercher des solutions
et s'il nous cherchons pas des solutions
par nous mêmes pour nous mêmes on risque
de continuer à se plaindre pendant très
longtemps
c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument
faire des propositions concrètes dans le
cas de ces assises pour qu'on puisse
éviter d'aller aux états unis à miami
pour revenir kingston en jamaïque à la
porte je connais les conditions
scabreuses
chaque fois qu'on reste étranger à notre
propre géographie et bien nous sommes
étrangers à nous mêmes alors
lorsque vous avez présenté ces assises
de l'aérien la semaine dernière ses
rejets chimiques il y avait pas mal
d'avionneur de compagnies aériennes et
au soudan dit j'ai quelque chose de très
très clair les fameuses taxes
ce sont les taxes qui plombe la poche du
voyageur les taxes qui plombe les
finances des avionneurs est ce qu'il y
aura matière à réflexion il ya matière à
réflexion et ce qui aura des pistes
encore accusé par la wii mais je pense
qu'il ya vraiment un vrai problème parce
que quand on a il ya un de ces deux ce
qui est que vous indiquez qui disait que
bien sûr un billet coûtait 250 europe
hall de 130 euros il y avait 180 euros
de taxes sont 70 euros de taxe ça normal
et j'ai même entendu une connectivité la
principale la martinique dix 10 ans
qu'il faut augmenter la taxe de deux des
passagers au profit de la collectivité
s'était même si j'ai entendu mais ce
n'est pas établi on va on va à l'envers
quoi dire ontex encore plus les gens le
prix du riz augmente et 60% du prix du
billet 70% ce sont des fiscalités
extrêmement complexe il faut voir ça et
c'est pas seulement un autre niveau au
niveau national il faut avoir et plus
particulièrement notre mère faut
chercher d'autres sources de financement
des collectivités que d'abuser de la
situation des passagers
alors vous avez évoqué également un pôle
formation pour tous qu'ils auraient
trait à l'aérien mais bon vous l'avez
évoqué un vous le martiniquais mais vous
savez lorsque nous ici en martinique on
aurait avancé une idée on est tout de
suite concurrencée par la guadeloupe on
a vu avec le cyclotron et victorin lurel
ce pôle de formation régional ce sera
une antenne martinique une antenne
guadeloupe acropole dans un des deux
pays ces pays et les assises
je rappelle que c'est coton on s'est
fait doubler nous-mêmes parlons mais
mince et c'est la matinée qui a traîné
sur le cyclotron qui a fait que la
grotte de barbie de l'avant sauf
qu'avant c'est vrai oui pas cadeau mais
quoi alors concernant cette affaire non
les gars et des bayous à discussion je
ne peux pas avancer des des solutions
avant même ces assises ont droit en
septembre des conclusions selon sue
certain c'est que il y à une attention
particulière du gouvernement sur la
question de faire un centre de formation
des métiers de l'aérien dans la caraïbe
c'est par moi de dire exactement où se
se fera et mais ça se fera
et ça nous permettra aussi de faire
venir des gens de la cara
des états unis d'amérique du sud dans
soixante deux formations notre marché
sera susceptible d'alimenter de toutes
ces personnes qui viennent normes et si
vous pensez marché en nous confiant la
comptabilité des 380 mille martiniquais
vous n'avez jamais rien faire il faut
absolument dans la tête et dans l'esprit
avant une connectivité aussi
intellectuelles et morales et disant que
ce marché ne peut concerner aussi des
panaméens des mexicains des jamaïcains
c'est comme ça désormais qu'il faut
penser autrement on pense à venir
expliqué on l'a un canal cerveau qui
vaquent à paris rien nulle part d'autre
merci d'avoir été ce match avec nous ça
jette chimie des petites la martinique
et président de ces assises de l'aérien
haut niveau outre mer merci bonne
journée